our next guest allegedly got his
distinctive nickname as a child and it's
too late to do anything about it now
play college football at LSU was the
first-round pick in 1999 apparently had
a long productive NFL career and won a
couple of Super Bowls but every story
pitchers find out about him now focuses
on that sideline contraption that blocks
everybody's view who sits behind him
please welcome the man who sits in the
movie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you look like you could still play a
little bit the key word is look I can't
though you couldn't give me a couple of
dollars I got one snap left and that's
it that's it what was the most you ever
weighed 335 where are you now
281 now is that good yeah that's great
okay it's like 50 pounds well you lost
50 pounds but I didn't have 50 pounds to
lose right I get it but ya know it's
great for me because making a lifestyle
change because I started eating a lot of
meat and a lot less sweets but also
there's been stories about guys when
when you're done with football right
yeah add weight correct I mean some guys
lose weight yeah but you know there are
stories where guys are getting close to
400 pounds here yeah you know so I
played my last year in India about 310
and then I heard my knee rehab came back
didn't want to sign with the Oakland
Raiders so now I get out of the game and
I gain 20 pounds because you're still
eating the same way but you're not doing
the same type of work on a day-in
day-out basis and then on top of that
you stand up late at night I'm gonna
Oreo guy okay Oreos another golden Oreos
too by the way
so golden Oreos and Nutter Butter
cookies my weakness that's what I said
oh yeah it's it's wrong and you just
keep doing that and then you get kids
and they like honey buns and now the
honey buns become part of the Oreos and
Nutter butters and 3:35 you know but I
you know it is weird like Joe Thomas I
saw him and Joe looks good he's lost
weight you know certain guys you know
they they're able to lose weight but you
know I wonder about that with these guys
who these guys probably had a hard time
keeping weight okay
and so like some guys have to eat 5 to 6
meals a day just to stay at weight if
they only ate normal meals like three
meals and a snack or two they lose
weight I never had that problem
are we still it feels like we're not
developing great offensive lineman the
way we wants to because of spread
offenses and the offensive linemen who
come into the NFL aren't ready for the
NFL because they played a different
system in college I completely agree
what's happening now is the NFL is
morphing into the college system yeah
and so at some point I think we're gonna
get further and further away from
developing the Allen Fanta cos of the
world like we're not gonna get back to
that point anymore because the
quarterbacks are changing think about
what they're doing in Baltimore
Baltimore is getting rid of Joe Flacco a
Super Bowl winning quarterback to morph
into Lamar Jackson and a band of misfits
that we're gonna run around and we're
gonna run the football nine times out of
ten would you do it no cuz I don't think
it's gonna work the NFL has always been
built on the quarterback position having
the ability to distribute the football
from the pocket stop saying my fingers
crooked I know I know I'll stop staring
at it oh I'm trying to give serious
analysis here and you stand in what do
you want me to look at seriously every
time I say something you like you know
well your hands are all screwed up first
of all my hands are not screwed up this
hand is perfect I have one - I have
three fingers look at my look at me I'm
showing the audience I only have two
fingers that are bad so eight out of ten
s 80% seriously but back to my original
point no it's a great Jill Flacco take
and I guess I screwed it up cuz I made
now done you know I don't think it's
gonna work in Boca I don't know you can
look at me now no see okay
now whenever I'm around linemen right
first thing I know is their hands
because there's some ones that go like
in directions that they shouldn't go out
of scars man that's hot here's the
wounds and I remember so this is 1998
we're playing Alabama yeah Sean
Alexander and I dislocated both of them
but this one was dislocated and the
trainer says coming to training room
tomorrow we'll put a little splint on it
but I mean I'm 19 years old and I'm like
okay I don't wanna walk around unless
you I'm already a little short fat guy
with a fro I don't wanna walk around
campus with like two metal things on my
finger it's gonna just look hot
so I didn't wear it and that's what
happens this is 2001 I think Emma Smith
got caught in a juries and I looked down
it's going that way
and it was my only it's the only time I
played against imminent Roy and there's
no way I was come out of their game
because like the Cowboys were my team
growing up I grew up in North Louisiana
yeah and so I'm only four hours from
Dallas I was going back in that game
without a doubt who are you often
mistaken for two people mark
Speirs and charles barking okay yeah
Marcus Pierce is because we both went to
LSU we both kind of ball and Charles
Barkley for three reasons one we're ball
we're bigger we have that southern
dialect and in my early early golf days
our swing was I'm not gonna say similar
but people will get it confused wait
were you that bad yeah because I was
still just learned how to pull okay yeah
yeah and you know I think the last
reason is people people love Charles
because Charles comes on TV and he's the
same way that he years off of television
my speaks his mind he tells it how and
that's the best kind of way I grew up I
was worrying if that you know there's
certain guys who were influencers yeah
you know there's gonna be a wave of
people trying to find the next Tony Romo
right you know Chris Berman with what he
did you know Bob cotton you know there's
guys and I was curious as an analyst who
is the guy that maybe has influenced you
the most in what you do it's probably
been a combination of two people I think
fragment I love Troy style because it's
simplistic it's effective it's easily
digestible and I love Charles Barkley
what he does because he's relatable and
I think when you can combine those
things people at home can say you know
what I can see myself talking to this
guy you know what you're doing it again
I can see myself talking to this guy at
a bar about football and to me that's
easily relatable and the people like
okay I can be friends with that guy and
so to me that's what I try to be like
and it's hard to do that when somebody
says be yourself you don't know who
yourself is when you're on TV it's a
comfort level there's a nervousness that
you get when you go on the field for the
first time the very first time you go on
television there's a little some
butterflies now though is the booger
mobile back next year I don't know we've
had early conversations if I had to bet
I would probably lean toward no but I'm
not in that final decision-making
process you guys sounded better when you
were in the booth yeah you did you made
Witten's sound better when you're in the
booth I think it's no different than you
and I having this conversation
yeah and the audience can see me as
opposed
- if I want a big giant screen and
you're talking and there's a half second
delay and which one do all that it's the
same thing you know FaceTime is great
until you can actually hug your kids
then it's not good you you rather be in
a room with them and so I think it's the
same way
he's booger McFarlane part of the
motherships Monday Night Football team
part of ESPN live and SportsCenter
coverage all week long you can be in
Dominic ensue or Aaron Donald now you
know you got to put pressure on Brady
which is easier said than done right but
how do you you got pressure on yourself
a putting pressure on Brady because if
you don't get it you're gonna kill you
if I could be either one of those guys
this week I'd want to be in Duncan soon
so I play with oneself I think once AB
is the best maybe at worst second best
defensive tackle ever to play the game
behind John Randle his words not mine so
I'm gonna agree with him there's gonna
be a lot of attention paid to Aaron
Donald you know Belichick is people
always say well he takes what you do
best and takes it away well don't most
coaches I mean shouldn't most coaches do
that and so bill is not gonna allow
Aaron erectus game last time that the
Patriots and Rams played Aaron Donnell
had three tackles one quarterback hit he
was a non-factor die was a December 2016
I think you're gonna see a similar
production sheet he's a better player
Bill's a better coach shag Mason is a
better God so now you can't double
everybody so who gets the one-on-one
Fowler he's gonna get the guy two six
eight and like a mountain at left tackle
so the guy that has to be dominant is in
dominance - yeah he's gonna get
one-on-one blocks and for all the things
that we made out of him coming out of
Nebraska should have won the Heisman
he's been a dominant player by and large
I've been disappointed with his career
because I think it should have been
better now the last couple of weeks he
has turned it on and when he turns it on
he is a son of a gun he is tough to deal
with he's got to be that way Sunday if
he's that way I don't think that the
Patriots can block that from four but
its own and amok ensued not Aaron Don he
can change his entire career perception
and one day yeah if he won the Super
Bowl if he was a big reason why they won
the Super Bowl we'll look at him
differently three sacks forced fumble
and we forget about the personal foul we
forget about some of the dumb plays that
he's made
we forget about kind of how he forced
his way out of Detroit a little bit and
he becomes a hero
we remember people that win on Sunday
yeah we don't remember the lose and I
think that's the the mindset that
players have to have gone into this game
the game is the same it's 60 minutes but
it's the hoopla around the game that's
gonna change in the the team that makes
it more normal and goes out and performs
the best I think it's gonna win and I'm
gonna lean toward the Rams right now a
lot I have faith that the Adamic ensue
I've seen the last two weeks I'm gonna
see and I can't see the tiger Lee I've
seen for the last month I think Todd
Gurley is gonna show back up who's been
one of the more productive players the
most productive running back in the
league last two years can you get into
Jared gulfs head as a veteran defensive
lineman in here he is you know
big stage young quarterback not as a
veteran defensive Lama but as a veteran
coordinator Jared golfed and Sean
McVeigh have this relationship and it
started you know after Jeff Fisher just
screwed golf's head up shame on Jeff
Fisher because he had us thinking that
Jared Goff was the buzz and now comes
Sean McVeigh says okay I'm gonna help
you my job as a coach is to help you
we're gonna get to the line of scrimmage
quickly the play clock or the player to
coach communication cuts off at 15
they're at the line of scrimmage at 25
he's still talking to Jared in his head
I'm helping you decipher what's out
there that's helped him become a better
quarterback now bring in Bill Belichick
when Belichick knows everything about
McVeigh cuz the last time Belichick
faced McVeigh he crushed it McVeigh said
I learned a lot that day about coaching
and putting players in the right
position so to your question can
defensive linemen get in Jared Goff head
no but Belichick can because the worst
thing a quarterback wants to see is a
picture that tells a lot because when
they break the holder they want to see
the picture that tells the truth
well Tech's not gonna show him that and
most good coordinators don't show you
that's the same picture they're gonna
show you a lie and then how fast can you
process the lie as a place naps and move
forwards to me that'll be the key for
Jericho when you last time you pop
somebody pop as in hit yeah we have this
thing on Monday night where we kind of
hit each other a little bit like we kind
of slap each other not in the face but
you want
being weird and test doesn't like it cuz
these are smaller one of us he's soft
yeah well I'm not gonna say soft he's
just a little lighter I mean Whigs 260
I'm 280 and so kind of physical dudes
like Paulie stand up and let booger pop
you like he does Monday night come here
now like now today right now we don't
want to do it doing a commercial break
yeah just see how it feels it's yeah so
I mean just to give you an example it'll
be something like this like we'll have a
conversation and we're talking
[Laughter]
normally normally the guy doesn't know
it's coming and so you get a broad chest
there's nothing like caving in a broad
chest what about a concave don't really
have a chest as I was waiting to come on
a show
I keep hearing I heard two words Traeger
and meet yeah where is it it's I'm
cooking it I don't smell anything
good meat outside can you bring it
inside you know they told me how to cook
it outside I can get you to go play two
brisket it's no fun brisket is better
hot fresh off the grill it'll be outside
we yeah I wanted to give you a critique
as I'm eating a brisket and while we're
doing this interview the reason people
love your show is because there's Chad
right there cooking the brisket I like
as we speak and Chad looks like he eats
brisket how can you tell yeah I'm gonna
get you brisket in the break and you can
have it to go okay I like it no no this
is I give you parting gifts I appreciate
that there's no other show giving you
brisket no it's not to me that shows us
cooking either that's true and we cook
in more ways than one
he's booger McFarlane
have great listen to you on Monday Night
Football and I hope you get into the
booth because I think the team sounds
better there's camaraderie there Booker
will be doing the Super Bowl for ESPN
Australia and New Zealand part of ESPN's
NFL live in Sports Center coverage for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]